president cyril ramaphosa says the riots
were a coordinated
and well-planned attack on south
africa's democracy
more than 200 people have been killed
the unrest was sparked by the jailing
of former president jacob zuma and
quickly developed into demonstrations
against poverty
and inequality bernie smith reports
from dermot and they just looted and
looted and looted
durbin has been quieter these last
couple of days but it's a calm
sometimes enforced at gunpoint ridwan
jetham
managed to protect his business but saw
many others looted and burned
it was the mob themselves that caused
all the destruction and
caused harm to themselves because we
were attacked and we had people
open fire on us and we basically have to
safeguard ourselves by hiding behind
walls and buildings
the writing was sparked by the jailing
of former president jacob zuma and
expanded to include wider grievances
it unleashed racial tensions that always
simmer beneath the surface here
the minister of police toured durbin's
townships on saturday
promising to investigate crimes
committed by all communities
as a team of detectives is investigating
the deaths of 20 black
people after confrontations with a
neighbouring indian majority township
but it's clear there is anger here that
is hard to contain
for now it looks difficult but we are
working together we are working with the
communities we go out to the streets to
speak to other people
we've got a problem with social media
social media is the main cause of this
because people are reacting to fake news
white minority rule ended nearly 30
years ago but most south africans
still live in racially separated
townships or suburbs
that were created by the apartheid
government these queues are
the only supermarket in a four kilometer
radius that wasn't
ransacked because it was defended by the
owners and local businesses
south africa state insurers says it's
expecting claims to top
700 million dollars at night durban's
different communities
are still closing themselves in behind
their own checkpoints there are outside
elements that are coming here
and get very upset when we have to ask
them what is your purpose here
people here are worried there's more
trouble to come
it's not quite it's not settling down
there's areas that no one's focusing on
and that's the concern
there are areas which are every day
there's blue team burning still
continuing
and no one sees that just hours after
south africa's president said on friday
night
that calm had been restored this market
was firebombed bernard smith al-jazeera
durbin south africa